[Music]
thanks denise
well in today's eight on your side there
is pent-up demand for travel unlike
anything we've ever seen before and
after a year of cancelled trips what
will it mean for our beloved cheap
flights
now with vaccinations accelerating and
folks eager to head back out to travel
after
more than a year for the pandemic we are
headed for a travel surge for
summer summer of course as you know is
already a popular time to travel the
others being christmas and new year's
scott kais of scott's cheap flight says
there are still cheap flights up for
grabs
but the availability of them for this
summer is set to wane
my advice for folks is if you're hoping
to travel this summer and you're hoping
to get a cheap flight
doing so booking sooner rather than
later is going to be your best bet
if you wait to book your flights even
let's say until may
chances are there's not going to be any
cheap flights left
and he says summer fights will also get
more expensive as time goes by
if you're interested scott has a new
book coming out next month called take
more vacations it explains why he says
we're searching for airfare all wrong
and share strategies to save you money
while booking